à quelques dizaines de mètres de la
salle de spectacle de la commanderie
cette petite plage au bord du doubs
attire les baigneurs un site non
surveillé ici on se baigne à ses risques
et périls
c'est la deuxième fois que les forts
courants sont à l'origine d'un drame
l'été 2016 déjà à père de famille
s'était noyé vient effectivement un
petit peu de courant mais la baignade
n'est pas surveillée qu'effectivement
chacun prend ses responsabilités il faut
éviter d'aller là où il ya trop de
courant pour éviter certains tourbillon
j'imagine comment tout rivière vous
savez qu'il ya eu des accidents l'an
dernier cette année tout à fait non que
chacun chacun doit faire attention et
effectivement prendre ses
responsabilités la prudence est donc de
mise pour cette jeune femme
mais cela suffit-il que peut faire la
municipalité la réglementation en la
matière est visiblement un casse tête
il n'y a pas de panneaux d'interdiction
mais aucune baignade non surveillée au
bord des rivières
partout où il n'y a pas de panneaux
c'est donc une baignade qui est sous la
responsabilité du baigneur et partout il
ya des panneaux pour indiquer que la
baignade est autorisée
et bien c'est le sous la responsabilité
de la collectivité qui en assurent la
sécurité
mais aujourd'hui sur la loue et sur le
doubs il n'y a pas de plages autorisées
avec une sécurité à la veille des
vacances les consignes de sécurité
doivent donc être régulièrement rappelée
même en zone surveillée la vigilance ce
n'est pas du luxe en 2016 et non un
traité 80 interventions pour des noyades
une s'est malheureusement terminé
dramatiquement comme celle de cette
année par un décès donc c'est une
situation qui existe l'intérêt pour les
gens c'est de se baigner en zone
surveillée ou alors en piscine
surveillée mme en tout cas là où on est
sûr de la sécurité sinon effectivement
le fait à ses risques et périls et les
statistiques prouvent que c'est
effectivement dangereux dès le 1er
juillet prochain à trente sapeurs
pompiers seront affectés à la
surveillance des cinq sites de baignade
du jura